hey guys my name is Danny and I'm one of
Evans videographers and my one word has
become and the reason why my one word
has become is because I used to struggle
a lot with self-identity and I've always
tried to become something else or
somebody you know so I was always trying
to become that person that I thought
everybody wanted me to be what I thought
everyone would thought was cool because
realistically I had no friends I was a
loner I went into high school scared
thinking I'm not gonna make any friends
and I really didn't make too many and
honestly it was to the point where I
realized that I needed to become who I
want to become and so every time I faced
with a struggle every time at any time
I'm faced with an obstacle right in
front of me I just tell myself become
that person that you're gonna become
that man that you believe you are and it
gets me through those times so when I
was in high school one of my biggest
obstacles one of the worst things that
ever really did to myself was I
committed food suicide is what I call it
and food suicide is you know just stuff
in your face with whatever you want
whenever you want all the time and it
got to the point where I gained over 80
to 100 pounds in one year doctors told
me I had to stop and I didn't and it got
to the point where I couldn't even walk
up a flight of stairs without getting
gas without getting tired and I I wish I
documented pictures and then videos
about so ashamed of my body that I
didn't do it
and mentally it affected me as well it
brought me into a big depression and I
just kept on doing that's a big big
rabbit hole that I dug myself under and
finally when I realized that I need to
change my lifestyle that I need to
become something better I actually went
on YouTube and I started looking at
motivational videos and one video of
that popped up that really got me going
was the Arnold Schwarzenegger
motivational video it's famous everybody
knows it but it is the one thing that I
listen to every single day when I worked
out while people are listening to the
latest trends and the latest songs and
the latest artists I was playing that
speech on repeat over and over and over
again in my headphones and then when I
came home I would listen to it when I
before I went to bed I will listen to it
sometimes when I wake up I listen to it
and it was just constant and I just
eventually it just it resonated and it
eventually just changed my mindset and
it got me through workouts it got me to
the gym it got me hyped up to actually
work out and change my life and continue
on the journey
weight loss and yes it was just one
speech and of course I loved Arnold's
movies and I loved them as you know just
as an entertainer and what I see on TV
at least his speech that one speech that
he made one speech changed a person's
life and made me become something
different it made me more motivated than
ever
it created Who I am today just from that
one speech and just listening to it over
and over and over again so his words
they saved my life and to me that makes
him a hero and I wish I could just say
thank you on Evans 2019 becoming tour
we're coming to California and I'd love
to meet Arnold if any of you watching
have a connection in it would make my
dream come true to shake his hand and
thank him for changing my life hopefully
it happens hopefully you know 2019 it
happens to as an 18 has been crazy for
me so 2019 here I come I don't have too
many expectations I'm realistic what if
it happens pretty awesome why don't
being realistic so with that being said
I look forward to 2019 becoming tour and
I hope you guys look forward to it as
well
one year ago I left myself this message
and I want to show it to you guys
because till this day it still reminds
me of the progression that I've made and
that I should keep going to become the
person I want to become thank you guys
so much for watching this I hope you
guys enjoy this message and it would
really really mean a lot to be able to
meet Arnold in real life so thank you
guys and continue to believe you know
I'm not gonna lie things like this get
pretty tough I mean you're literally
working all night long all day long and
don't get it twisted guys it's not like
you make a lot of money not yet you know
it's
then working from pretty much morning
and now it's like three o'clock and I
haven't even we haven't even touched the
editing you know and you guys know what
it's like getting into the editing room
but I'm just getting in my car right now
and I'm you know you guys will see this
but phone's almost dead it is you
probably can't see it it's 220 in the
morning I have about a 15-minute commute
back to my condo at home you know it's
is weird because like if this was any
other job I wouldn't be able to do this
like all day long you know from 10
o'clock in the morning when I left the
condo originally sent out two o'clock in
the morning standing all day walking all
day it goes any other job in the world I
couldn't do it but even days like this
when it's tough it's tiring it's
exhausting both mentally and physically
you know you're hungry you go 12 hours
without eating me and Brittany went like
a Love
and nearly 12 no water
you know like days like this do you're
gonna have days like this so all y'all
filmmakers out there who want to do this
just be ready and but if you love doing
this then really all of this everything
I'm saying almost doesn't matter you
know you use kind of accept it but
that's the whole point of this vlog is
to show young filmmakers out there who
are aspiring to do things that we're
doing where you're you're out on the
field all the time and you know you're
just trying to make it out of your own
pocket you know this is me brahim trying
to make it out of wrong pocket you know
investing in ourselves
this is sacrifice and
you spend your weekends you know doing
doing what you love instead of going on
having a social life or spending time
with your loved ones your family your
friends whatever it may be you're doing
this for for-4 that dream and the bigger
picture
you see this this vision Asst ahead and
it's
it's the only reason why right now at
this time my eyes are still awake
this is part of the sacrifice guys
I don't know why I decided to get so
deep is just when you when you're
standing there on set and you're doing
this it's like
I guess you just kind of reflected a
little bit like wow I'm really spending
all day doing this from just doing this
for fun to like I'm literally doing this
all day long and it can get overwhelming
sometimes and no matter how tired how
hungry how thirsty how exhausted
mentally you are knowing that you know
you stuff so much things to do outside
of just filming you know you have life
to deal with and it's like it can get
overwhelming sometimes but like the
grind is just there's something
bittersweet about it it's like like I
said I hope there's nothing else I would
do this for and nothing I would rather
do one Saturday night there's nothing
else I would rather do so that wraps up
this vlog episode three
I hope those of you who are watching to
see what the life is about this gives
you kind of an idea in that if you love
it and you have the heart for it well
this is what it takes and and trust me
this would be more of a I don't know
describe and more of a
motivational feeling in a way but I
can't lie and tell you that it's always
Happy's always impersonations it's
always fun it's always laughter you do
it you know most of the time that's how
I try to keep it you know I'm Abraham
we're always trying to keep it fun but
uh you get nice like this we're just
reality hits
and there's some things that
you when you spend so many hours you
realize all the things you're
sacrificing but you also realize that
that it's worth it so stay strong I know
I will and thanks for watching us peace